in the left side four rows back aya mike
bond with rolling stone but they held
you you know pretty intact in that first
half but and the second you were able to
open up a little more what were they
doing that was effective in the first
half there I mean they did a good job
both halves of no place in my picking
Rose keeping the third guy in the bag
not letting me play one-on-one just
really like tilling their defense you
know that's pretty much it it's not
letting me get no easy looks bring a
tool to the ball and thought get by that
third guys coming that um you know my
teammates play well tonight so man it's
a team game if they're gonna play like
that then you know you know guys are
gonna play well get wide open shots
fifth row on the right side to Jo Jo
Vardhan from the athletic Kauai
everybody knows the Warriors have been
in the last four finals they've won
three all that it what was your
conversations like in the locker room
the last couple days leading up to this
it was there some sort of discussion
about how they're you know they're human
just like everybody else or just trying
to bring them down down a level no we
don't have conversations like that we
know that they're human I mean they're
great basketball team talented players
high basketball IQ players you know you
just got to go out there and compete
take the challenge we know they're gonna
make no big shots go home runs and it's
a bell just keeping your composure and
keep fighting through don't put your
head down when you know you know players
Steph or clay make big threes just keep
playing or throw in the middle Kayla
quite Kayla car a TSN got a great night
from Pascal siakam being on the floor
with him what did he add to the game for
you guys tonight he's played well on
both ends of the floor
you know he got to the paint he'd
knocked down his shots his wide-open
shots tonight he was aggressive on both
ends of the floor got his hands
deflections on a lot of basketballs
tonight big block shots big Bucky so let
me play Lou
well I better go back to the gentleman
in the blue on the right side wobbly
table eso you spoke about this a little
bit earlier but can you kind of talk
about how your teammates really
compliment you expect especially when
they are a double teaming you so
aggressively but how do you you know
kind of go about your way of getting
them going and how that kind of really
brings the crowd into everything I mean
just keep being aggressive you know we
played you know teams throughout this
playoff so it's playing a similar
defense and I guess just learning from
experiences and guys being ready and
just keep being aggressive and make sure
I make the right play and don't be
trying to be a hero out there just play
basketball that's what I'll do
left side fifth row gonna go to a rash
Kauai tear left here on the aisle a rash
medallion with Sportsnet they got it to
within three they got to within four in
the fourth quarter and you guys were
able to have an answer a couple of times
how are you able to do it to withstand
them like I said don't get too down
there great basketball team just keep
fighting keep striving don't give up and
just have a confidence just have
confidence in yourself that you're gonna
win the game I mean that's all you could
do laid out on the floor and see what
happens
better go to the right side of the six
rows back Dan Feldman NBC Sports before
you succeeded so much in the finals you
weren't universally recognized as a star
Pascal siakam wasn't an all-star this
year I'm wondering if you talked to him
at all or he talked to you about
capitalizing on competing on this stage
he doesn't need he doesn't need no prep
talk so
he's going out there doing it he's not a
goddess
you know shine away he he's very
aggressive when he's on the floor and I
mean when we talk is this a group effort
you know what I mean and hopefully
everybody hears it in brings it to the
game
takes the knowledge when we are you know
you know put in you know our knowledge
and experience from past times and
that's all we could do is it's a team
basketball game any other questions in
the back on the left why Jonathan show
with dia TV Katie didn't play today he
may not be playing the next game as well
at the same time are you preparing for
him are you thinking about how to
prepare for a Kevin Durant if he does
return during the series for sure I mean
whenever he does play our say he's gonna
be playing in we're definitely gonna
have to you know prep for him you know
he's another guy I could just score 30
points in his sleep and I mean everybody
know who he is and for sure we're gonna
have to prep for him thank you